We're so pleased to have, as I said, Bernard and Betsy here at church with us this morning.
And I first met Bernard in England, and he was coming to Stoke-on-Trent.
This is what, 16, 17 years ago, something like that, where we were living.
And there was like an evangelistic mission where you could bring folks who were non-Christians,
who wanted to hear more about the Christian faith to come.
And I remember bringing friends to that, and Bernard was the one who faithfully preached the Gospel that day.
And full circle, the Lord has brought us both to Birmingham.
I'm from here, but Bernard, where are you from?
I am not from here, as you'll quickly be able to see from my British accent.
So I, thank you Julia.
I am from London, England, and I moved to New York in 2012.
And a few years afterwards, met Betsy.
We got married in 2015.
And then in 2023, Betsy pulled me back to her hometown of Birmingham.
And very happily so, I'm very happy to be here.
It's great to be here in Alabama.
We're glad to have you here.
Could you maybe tell us, I mean, when Julia and I are out, people hear her accent.
And they say, OK, well, where did you meet?
How did you end up here?
You both have an interesting, everybody's story of how they met is interesting.
But you guys have an interesting story about how you met.
How did you meet?
Well, Betsy wrote an article for a website called the Gospel Coalition.
And it was an article about singleness, being single.
And I was single.
I read this article about Betsy, written by Betsy, about her being single.
And I did a little googling and found her email address.
And I sent her an email.
And she replied.
That was the important part.
And then we started emailing and video calling.
And then I flew down to Birmingham to take her out on a date.
Pretty expensive first date right there.
But it went very well.
And we kept dating.
And a year later, got married a year after I read that article.
Praise God.
Absolutely.
Yeah, it's wonderful that you're both here.
And the Lord's used you in different ways.
I mentioned you preaching the gospel in stoke and been involved in church planting and pastoring.
But you didn't grow up in a Christian household.
So I'd love for you to share more about what life was like growing up for you and in your background.
And then eventually, how did you end up coming to faith?
Sure.
I am from a Jewish background.
Pretty what's known as liberal Jewish, which basically means bacon at the weekends is fine if you're liberal Jewish.
So we literally have bacon at the weekends and enjoy it.
And synagogue a few times a year, two or three times a year at most.
But I did go through the bar mitzvah process, which you do when you're 13.
And that was that was quite important to me because after going through that, I said to myself, there's nothing there.
It's just it's just dry ritual.
There's no there are no big answers.
I'm not getting the meaning of life here.
So I then started to look elsewhere and I went to my high schools little Christian group.
There are 1,250 kids at my high school and about 20 or 30 at the little Christian group.
But there I had the I actually had this same passage that I'll be preaching on later.
The speaker was on the same passage.
And I don't think I'd ever heard the gospel before.
It was very fresh and very wonderful, particularly the message of eternal life.
That was what really gripped me because I'd sort of in teenagers have time to think and I'd reach the view that if we all die and then we're forgotten, what is the point?
And that really bothered me, really bothered me.
So to hear that there was a way to live forever through faith in Jesus, that was fantastic news.
I went straight up to the speaker and said, this sounds great, but I'm Jewish.
So, you know, I guess it's not for me.
Fortunately, he was an extremely direct person.
So he said, of course it's for you.
Jesus was Jewish.
If you follow him, you're following your own Messiah.
And he told me about a friend of his who was Jewish and had begun following Jesus and said that he now felt even more Jewish because he was following his own Messiah.
So that was really reassuring.
I needed that direct word.
And I think I think I began following Jesus that night of first hearing the gospel.
Yeah.
Um, so you began growing as a disciple.
The Lord called you into ministry and we're covering a lot of ground and you'd be very happy to speak with folks about ministry involvement.
So you evolved in church planting in Manhattan.
You've been involved in pastoral ministry.
We're a church plant that is almost a year in and we've had conversations and I've kind of picked your brains a little bit about church planting.
I'd love if you could maybe share a little bit of advice for us as a church a year into just getting started.
What would you say to us as a new church family?
Um, well, I think I'd say one thing to you and one thing to the congregation.
So one thing to brand and would be something is going to be hard.
It might be numbers or finances or an issue with the with your venue, your location, your meeting place or something else.
Something will be hard and that is very normal.
Push on through persevere by the grace of God.
And then to the congregation, I think I'd say, please don't expect Trinity Fellowship Church to be providing everything that are fully established.
Long established church will provide the years allow for church members to really bring their gifts to the table and set up programs and just get things.
Tickety boo, do you say that in America?
You know what I mean?
Tickety boo.
But you need to give it time and not expect a newborn church, a very recently planted church to have all the things that a long established church will have.
So put up with some rough and ready stuff along the way.
Be patient with the church.
That's what I would say to you guys.
Thank you so much.
I mean, it may be perfect already.
So that may be unnecessary.
We've got a long ways to go.
What about just right where you're at personally and as a family right now?
How can we be praying for you?
And then I'll turn it over to you to bring God's word to us, but look to pray for you.
Yeah, it'd be great if you could pray.
We went and when we moved to Alabama two years ago, I began pastoring a church in just near Homewood.
And that went on for two years, two good years, but we decided in the end that it probably be best for me to leave that particular
pastorship.
So I stepped down there nothing by the grace of God, nothing disgraceful.
Just wasn't quite the right fit.
So we are between jobs, which I say with faith, because I don't know that there will be another job at the end of it.
But we're praying to God that he'll provide something.
Yeah, absolutely.
Well, let's let's pray.
Lord, great is your faithfulness.
Lord, we know you call us to wait upon you.
And Lord, sometimes that is hard to wait upon you.
But Lord, we thank you that as we wait upon you, we can trust that you are faithful.
And Lord, as we walk by faith, we can trust that you are leading the way and that your goodness and mercy is following us every single day of our lives.
And one day we will dwell in the house of the Lord forever.
And this Lord, I thank you so much for how you have guided and provided for both Bernard and Betsy.
Lord, thank you so much for this wonderful story we've heard of how you brought him to faith in Jesus to embrace Jesus as the Messiah.
And Lord, thank you for how you have led them to each other and led them forward in ministry.
And Lord, as we look to your faithfulness and provision in the past, Lord, we know that we can trust you for the future.
Lord, you did not spare your own son, but delivered him up for us all.
How shall you not also with him freely give us all things?
And so, you've done the greatest thing.
So Lord, I pray that you would provide for them and guide them in the days ahead.
Lord, I just pray for us now as we come to hear your word proclaimed.
Lord, I pray that we would come with expectant hearts.
Lord, I pray that you would provide what we need this morning through your servant as he brings your word.
In Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen.
OK.
Thanks, Brandon.
Well, thank you very much for inviting me to be with you today.
From the moment I heard that Brandon and Julia were planting a new church north of Birmingham,
I've been rooting for you guys and praying for this church to be firmly established.
We are going to be looking at the Bible passage printed on this page of their service program, service bulletin.
And I will read that out now.
I'm only going to go down as far as verse 15.
There is nothing wrong with verses 16 through 21.
Nothing wrong at all.
But I'm only going to go as far as verse 15 today.
John chapter two, verse 23 through chapter three, verse 15.
Now, when he was in Jerusalem at the Passover feast,
many believed in his name when they saw the signs that he was doing.
But Jesus on his part did not entrust himself to them because he knew all people
and needed no one to bear witness about man, for he himself knew what was in man.
Now, there was a man of the Pharisees named Nicodemus, a ruler of the Jews.
This man came to Jesus by night and said to him, Rabbi,
we know that you are a teacher come from God,
for no one can do these signs that you do unless God is with him.
Jesus answered him, truly, truly, I say to you, unless one is born again,
he cannot see the kingdom of God.
Nicodemus said to him,
how can a man be born when he is old?
Can he enter a second time into his mother's womb and be born?
Jesus answered, truly, truly, I say to you, unless one is born of water and the spirit,
he cannot enter the kingdom of God.
That which is born of the flesh is flesh, and that which is born of the spirit is spirit.
Do not marvel that I said to you, you must be born again.
The wind blows where it wishes and you hear its sound,
but you do not know where it comes from or where it goes.
So it is with everyone who is born of the spirit.
Nicodemus said to him, how can these things be?
Jesus answered him, are you the teacher of Israel?
And yet you do not understand these things?
Truly, truly, I say to you, we speak of what we know
and bear witness to what we have seen, but you do not receive our testimony.
If I have told you earthly things and you do not believe,
how can you believe if I tell you heavenly things?
No one has ascended into heaven except he who descended from heaven, the Son of man.
And as Moses lifted up the serpent in the wilderness,
so must the Son of man be lifted up
that whoever believes in him may have eternal life.
This is the word of the Lord.
Thanks be to God.
Well, before we start, please join me in praying for God's help.
Let's bow our heads.
In Jeremiah chapter 15, Jeremiah says to God,
when your words came, I ate them.
They were my joy and my heart's delight.
Father, we pray that like Jeremiah,
we would find that your words are our joy and our heart's delight.
We ask this for Jesus' sake.
Amen.
Let me tell you about Adam.
Adam was a friend of mine at high school.
And it wouldn't surprise me if there was someone like him at your high school, too.
Adam did everything the way it ought to be done.
You always got a schoolwork handed in on time.
He was never in trouble with his teachers.
He was friendly to everyone and everyone liked him.
His default facial expression was a cheerful smile.
His clothes were always clean and tidy.
When Adam reached his senior year,
no one was surprised when the school gave him leadership responsibilities.
Did you have an Adam at your high school?
Maybe it was you.
Maybe you are the kind of person who other people would think of
in the way I think of Adam, the guy who did everything the way it ought to be done.
Well, if we could ask the people who lived in Jerusalem 2000 years ago
to think of someone like Adam, who they've known at high school,
one name would instantly come to their minds, Nicodemus.
He's introduced in chapter three, verse one.
Now there was a man of the Pharisees named Nicodemus, a ruler of the Jews.
We're told, first of all, that he's a Pharisee.
And the Pharisees were famous for lawkeeping.
Nicodemus would have spent all his waking hours
thinking about God's commands and trying to obey them.
The big ones do not murder, do not steal,
but also the less well-known ones.
Like Adam at my high school, Nicodemus never seemed to step out of line.
We're also told in verse one of chapter three
that Nicodemus was a ruler of the Jews.
Only a few Pharisees were included on the Jewish ruling council,
which means even among the Pharisees,
Nicodemus stood out as one of their best men.
He was Pharisee of the month again and again.
There's something else we're told about Nicodemus,
which is that he came to see Jesus at night.
Why would he do that?
Why would he go to Jesus at night instead of during the day?
It's something you do if you're meeting someone controversial
and you think it's best if people don't know about that.
They don't know that you're going to see this controversial person.
At that time, Jesus was a controversial figure
with a questionable reputation.
Unlike Nicodemus, Jesus was considered unsound.
So Nicodemus looks this way and that way to check.
There's no one else around, no one watching.
He makes his way to Jesus lodgings with his collar up high
and his hat down low.
This nighttime visit to Jesus shows that Nicodemus is the one
with the rock solid reputation at this time.
Well, I really want to hear what Jesus has to say to Nicodemus,
this Pharisee who never seems to put a foot wrong,
this first century equivalent to my high school friend, Adam.
John's Gospel tells us from chapter one onwards
that Jesus was God come down from God to live among us.
So Jesus' conversation with Nicodemus shows us what God has to say
to someone who always does things by the book.
What does God come down, say to Nicodemus,
this model citizen, let's find out?
Three times in this Bible passage in verses three, five and 11,
Jesus says the words, truly, truly, I say to you.
And each truly, truly I say to you statement
has something to do with being born again.
These three statements reveal what Jesus thinks of Nicodemus.
We're going to look at all three
of the truly, truly I say to you statements
and that will take us through to the end of the sermon.
The first is in verse three, Jesus says to Nicodemus,
truly, truly I say to you, unless one is born again,
he cannot see the kingdom of God.
In other words, no one can see the kingdom of God
without being born again.
Give a little thought to that and you'll see,
it is a crushing put down for the human race,
including Nicodemus.
No one can see the kingdom of God
without being born again.
Imagine a guy has finally got to the point
of saying to a girl, would you like to,
I was just wondering if,
what I'm trying to say is,
would you like to go out on a date with me?
And the woman he's asking looks him in the eye
and says, let me give you an honest answer.
I'm afraid you'd need to be born again
as a different person before I'd consider going out with you.
What an absolutely crushing put down.
What a crushing response.
There is no way that guy can reply.
So you're saying there's a chance.
No, no, she is saying there is no chance.
She's saying there's absolutely no chance whatsoever
unless he's somehow born again as a different person.
I hope we're all feeling a little bit hurt
on behalf of that guy.
I want us to feel the full force
of being rejected unless you're born again.
We need to feel the force of that
because that is what Jesus is saying
to each one of us here today.
His message is that no one,
no one can see the kingdom of God
without being born again.
And we can tell he really means that.
We can tell he's not exaggerating
because the person he's speaking to is Nicodemus,
the lawkeeper.
Before we move on to the next truly truly,
I say to you statement,
we need to ask what Jesus means
by the kingdom of God.
What is this kingdom that we can't get into
without being born again?
Nicodemus seems to grasp the kingdom part
of Jesus' message without any difficulty.
He doesn't say kingdom, well, kingdom.
He has a lot of trouble with the born again part
as we'll see later on,
but he doesn't have any trouble
with the kingdom part of Jesus' message.
That's because in that day and age,
the Jewish people were all expecting
the kingdom of God to come.
At that point in history,
Israel was part of the Roman Empire.
Bad times from the Jewish point of view, bad times.
But they all knew from the Hebrew Bible,
the Old Testament, that a new kingdom was on the way.
The kingdom of God, the prophet Daniel,
had predicted the God of heaven
will establish a kingdom that will never be destroyed.
That's from Daniel chapter two.
The God of heaven will establish a kingdom
that will never be destroyed.
That's the kingdom Jesus is talking about,
an indestructible kingdom established by God himself,
a kingdom of peace and joy that goes on forever.
The Jewish people were eagerly looking forward to it.
And that's why Jesus' statement is such a bombshell.
Truly, truly I say to you,
unless one is born again,
he cannot see the kingdom of God.
Jesus is saying to Nicodemus
that fine, upright, well-respected religious leader,
you won't get into the coming kingdom
unless you become a new person.
Something must be wrong with humanity.
If even Nicodemus can't enter the kingdom of God
without being born again,
and something is wrong with humanity,
that's exactly what Jesus thinks about the human race.
Something is wrong with us.
Take a look at the verses that come
just before Jesus' conversation with Nicodemus.
So that's the last few verses of chapter two.
John says, now when he, that's Jesus,
was in Jerusalem at the Passover feast,
many believed in his name
and they saw the signs that he was doing.
In other words, the miracles that he was performing,
Jesus was performing.
Then verse 24,
but Jesus on his part did not entrust himself to them
because he knew all people
and needed no one to bear witness about man,
for he himself knew what was in man.
John tells us many people believed in Jesus
because of his miracles,
but then John says Jesus didn't entrust himself to them,
meaning he didn't put himself in their hands.
Why not?
End of verse 24, he knew all people.
End of verse 25, he knew what was in man.
Jesus knew that beneath our smiling, pleasant faces
we have hearts that can't be relied on to do the right thing.
15 years ago, I visited Auschwitz,
the Nazi death camp where more than a million people,
mostly Jews, were murdered.
It is a chilling, horrifying place to visit.
Throughout that visit, there was one Bible verse
I couldn't stop thinking about.
It kept coming back to my mind
as I saw all the evidence of human depravity at Auschwitz.
And it was one of the verses I've just read,
John 2, verse 25,
Jesus needed no one to bear witness about man,
for he himself knew what was in man.
The 7,000 Nazi soldiers who staffed Auschwitz,
who ran Auschwitz,
they were ordinary people like you and me.
You might be thinking, no,
I would never have done what they did at Auschwitz.
I'd have refused to do it.
Really?
Can you be sure about that?
It's one thing to say you'd rather die
than send innocent people to their deaths.
But it's another thing to put that into practice.
Isn't it at least possible that to save your own life,
you'd have gone along with the flow,
doing what you were told to do to all those helpless people
while trying not to think too carefully
about what you were doing?
Jesus knew what was in man, it says in John 2, 25.
Jesus knew that our hearts aren't reliably good
in all circumstances.
And that's why he tells Nicodemus,
Nicodemus of all people,
that no one can see the kingdom of God
without being born again.
We don't qualify in our natural state
for that eternal kingdom of peace and joy.
But the method of this Bible passage
and the whole point of Jesus' conversation
with Nicodemus,
is that we can be born again.
And that brings us to the next truly truly I say to you statement.
It's in verse five, truly truly I say to you,
unless one is born of water and the spirit,
he cannot enter the kingdom of God.
That statement makes no sense to Nicodemus.
He doesn't understand what Jesus is talking about.
He makes a joke out of it.
He says in verse four,
how can a man be born when he was born?
Can he enter a second time into his mother's womb and be born?
All the mother's present today will be relieved to hear
that Jesus doesn't reply, that's it.
That's what I'm talking about.
Re-entering your mother's womb.
Imagine the discussion you'd need to have with your mother
if that is what it meant to be born again.
Mom, there's something we need to talk about.
Well, what's that dear?
Well, you remember how it was when I was born?
That coming out of your womb thing?
Yes, dear, how could I forget?
Well, how would you feel about giving birth to me again?
I kind of do over.
Obviously I'm bigger now, so that will make it difficult,
but would you be willing to give it a try?
What are you talking about, dear?
But if that's not what Jesus means,
what exactly does he mean when he talks about
being born for a second time?
We can tell Jesus is looking back to the Old Testament here,
because in verse 10, he says to Nicodemus,
are you the teacher of Israel?
And yet do not understand these things.
He's surprised that Nicodemus isn't tracking with him.
That shows Jesus, that shows that what Jesus is saying
about being born of water and the Spirit,
it must be standard Old Testament teaching.
The kind of teaching Nicodemus should already have known about.
And there is one Old Testament passage
that's particularly relevant.
It's in the book of Ezekiel.
It's a prediction that God will take something
away from his people and he'll also give something
to his people.
And the result for them will be new life,
like dried bones, regaining flesh and sinews and skin
and breath and coming back to life.
Here's what God will take away from his people
according to Ezekiel, all their wrongdoing and sin.
God says in Ezekiel 36, I will sprinkle clean water on you
and you shall be clean from all your uncleannesses.
I will cleanse you from all your sins.
That promise was fulfilled through Jesus' death.
From God's point of view, everyone deserves condemnation
and punishment except Jesus.
But when Jesus died on the cross,
he was punished for other people's sins.
That's what God takes away when he gives new life.
He takes away sin and wrongdoing.
It's all washed away.
And here's what God gives a new heart.
Here's another quote from Ezekiel 36.
I will give you a new heart and put a new spirit in you.
I will put my spirit in you and move you
to follow my decrees and be careful to keep my laws.
Just think about what God is offering.
All your sins washed away and a new heart
powered by God's spirit.
That is new life.
That's the second birth Jesus is telling Nicodemus about.
Let's press on to the third and final.
Truly, truly I say to you statement in the passage.
The first one dealt with the why of the new birth.
Why do we need it?
The second statement dealt with the what of the new birth.
What exactly is it?
And this last statement deals with the how question.
How do people get hold of this new birth for themselves
so they can enter the kingdom of God
and live there forever?
I can't think of a more important question
than this question of how to claim the new birth
for yourself.
Let's look down to verse 11
for the third truly, truly I say to you statement.
Starts in verse 11 and it flows all the way
to the end of verse 15.
Truly, truly I say to you, we speak of what we know
and bear witness to what we have seen
but you do not receive our testimony.
If I have told you earthly things and you do not believe
how can you believe if I tell you heavenly things?
We'll pause there.
That's build up what we've just heard, a drum roll.
Jesus is saying to Nicodemus,
are you sure you're ready for this?
Then in verse 13, Jesus underlines his own credentials.
He says, no one has ascended into heaven
except he who descended from heaven, the Son of Man.
Whenever Jesus talks about the Son of Man,
he's talking about himself.
So what he's saying in verse 13
is that he knows what he's talking about
because he's the only one who has come down from heaven.
Then in verses 14 and 15,
Jesus gets to the heart of the matter,
the drum roll is over.
This is the how of new life, verse 14.
And as Moses lifted up the serpent in the wilderness,
so must the Son of Man be lifted up
that whoever believes in him may have eternal life.
The part about the serpent in the wilderness
is something that happened when the Israelites
were on their way from Egypt to the promised land of Canaan.
There was a sudden plague of venomous snakes along the way.
They kept slithering into the Israelites tents.
It was terrifying.
One snake bite was a death sentence.
But God gave the people a solution to that terrible problem.
Moses was told to make a bronze snake
and fix it to a pole.
Here's a quote from the Old Testament.
This is God talking about that bronze snake on the pole.
God says, anyone who is bitten can look at it and live.
Anyone who is bitten, God told the Israelites,
can look at it and live.
Moses then quickly made a bronze snake,
put it on a pole and when anyone was bitten by a snake,
and then looked at that bronze snake, that person lived.
A look was enough to save.
So in verse 15, Jesus is saying that the Son of Man,
that's him, he is going to be lifted up
like that snake in Moses' time.
And that happened when Jesus was crucified,
his hands and feet were nailed to the cross,
which meant that his whole body was lifted up off the ground.
And just as looking at the bronze snake,
saved the snake bitten Israelites,
so a look of faith at Christ crucified brings new life.
It brings about the second birth.
There is no new life without faith in Christ.
My favorite movie is Master and Commander,
starring Russell Crow.
Anyone?
I've got one nodding head there.
It's about Jack Aubrey, a ship's captain
in the early 1800s.
The movie is based on a series of novels
and in most of those books, Captain Jack Aubrey
chases after French or Spanish ships
trying to win a great victory for the Royal Navy.
In one of the books, the British ships
have just caught sight of the French fleet.
And the chase has begun.
And the book says this about Jack Aubrey.
His heart was bubbling high,
that old splendid feeling of more,
far more than common life.
His heart was bubbling high,
that old splendid feeling of more,
far more than common life.
John chapter three is telling us this morning,
we don't need to join the Navy
and leadership into battle against the French
to have more, far more than common life.
We can have abundant life, fullness of life,
here and now in our current circumstances,
through faith in Jesus.
It's a life of love because born again people
have a loving relationship with the risen Lord Jesus.
Now behind the scenes that needs to be said,
God is in charge of the new birth.
God's sovereignty, His lordship over the whole process
is seen at the start of verse eight
where Jesus says, the wind blows where it wishes.
That's Jesus' way of saying,
we ourselves can't predict who will receive new life from God.
It's God's decision.
But from our point of view,
new life begins when we look with faith
at Jesus lifted up on the cross.
A look of faith that Christ crucified
brings a person all the blessings of the second birth.
Have you done that yet?
Have you looked?
If you haven't, you could look with faith
at Christ crucified today.
Like those snake-bitten Israelites
who looked at the bronze snake and were saved,
if you look at Christ crucified with real faith,
you will be born again.
Maybe like Nicodemus,
you've never realized that you need to be born again.
Maybe you've been thinking that trying your best
is the way to please God.
If so, I hope Jesus' words have got through to you this morning.
In our own nature, relying on our own strength,
we can't please God.
We keep falling short of the people,
of being the people we really ought to be.
We need God's help,
or else we face His condemnation and punishment.
We need God to take away our sins and give us His Spirit.
Please, if you've always been on the outside looking in,
look with faith today at Christ crucified.
Being born again won't change you in every way.
The same face will look back at you
in the mirror each morning.
You'll have the same likes and dislikes
when it comes to breakfast cereals
and college football teams.
And even with a new heart,
it is still challenging to live life God's way.
Bad stuff that you used to find tempting
will probably still be very tempting.
But alongside the continuity, there will be real change.
For example, you'll be able to fight temptation
with new spiritual power that you didn't have before.
Being born again is real change happening to regular people.
It is not wishful thinking, it is not religious waffle.
It is real change to regular people.
Nicodemus himself seems to have got the message.
Later in John's Gospel in chapter seven,
when all the religious leaders are attacking Jesus,
Nicodemus stands up for him.
And after Jesus has died, Nicodemus comes alongside
Joseph of Arimathea to give Jesus an honorable burial.
We don't know for sure, but it certainly looks
as if Nicodemus responded to Jesus' message with faith.
We've thought about the why of the new birth,
why it's necessary, we've thought about
the what of the new birth.
What is it?
All our sins washed away, the spirit put in our hearts,
and we've just been thinking about the how of the new birth,
how it happens from our point of view,
that look of faith at Christ crucified.
I wanna finish with a message to those of us
who have already been born again in the past.
Praise God.
Those of us who are confident that in his love,
his great love, God has given us new life.
That's most of us probably, or maybe all of us,
here today, here is the message.
Live out your new life.
Live it out.
Keep the new you activated.
Don't settle back into the old you
and your old way of life.
We have power as God's reborn people to live life his way.
He tells us about that new life in the Bible
and he gives us the power we need to live it.
How does that play out in practice?
Well, when we're tempted to have yet another day
without reading the Bible or spending time in prayer,
we can live out our new life by asking God to help us,
push social media to one side
and devote some time to him alone,
reading his word, listening to his voice and his word,
praying to him.
Or when we see someone in our church family with a need,
we can live out our new life by serving that needy person,
bearing their burdens.
The old way of life is a shoulder shrugging,
can't be bothered way of life,
at least that's how it was for me,
but born again people can rise above that by God's power.
We have the spirit of God dwelling within us
and he empowers us to live life God's way,
bearing one another's burdens, loving one another.
Another way to live out our new life
is to live with hope instead of despair.
America has been through a rough week
and it's right for us to grieve when we see a public figure
shot dead on a college campus.
It's right for us to grieve, but we shouldn't despair.
Born again people will see the kingdom of God,
we'll enter into it and live there forever.
That kingdom is coming and there will be no tears in it.
It will be a place of perfect justice.
Jesus will himself be there.
As born again people, one of the ways in which we live out
our new life is by looking forward to what is to come.
Our hope isn't pinned to this world.
We're citizens of heaven, the best is yet to come.
New heavens and a new earth.
What will it mean for you to activate the new you
to live it out, this born again you during the week ahead?
What might be different for you if you live out
this new life instead of settling for the old way
of doing things?
Born again Christian, you have power from God
to live life his way.
Make use of that power to the glory of Jesus Christ.
Let's pray.
Father in heaven, we thank you for making it possible for us
to be born again through the sacrificial death
of your son Jesus and by sending your spirit.
Help us Father to live out this new life you've given us.
Help us to keep it activated day by day.
And if there's anyone here not yet born again,
please give them this new life in your grace and mercy.
Help that person look with faith at Christ crucified.
Amen.